[Music]
the prime minister in brussels if you
thought he had headaches at home what
he's walking into here is far more
serious
two allies and a return to fist bump
diplomacy but so much more is necessary
neither the pm nor nato sure which way
this crisis is heading but they do know
the stakes are dangerously high
the number of russian forces is going up
the warning time for a possible attack
is going down
nato is not a threat to russia
but we must be prepared for the worst
are you coming to the conclusion that
president putin actually wants
this war to answer your question
directly about what i think is going on
in moscow and the calculations that are
being made there i
i don't i honestly don't think a
decision has yet been taken but that
doesn't mean
that it is
uh
impossible that something absolutely
disastrous could happen very soon indeed
and our intelligence i'm afraid
to to say remains
grim this is probably the most dangerous
moment
i would say in the in the course of the
next few days in what is the uh biggest
security crisis that uh europe has faced
for decades and
we've got to get it right the race to
get it right very visible the pm dashing
from brussels to warsaw in poland
2pm standing shoulder to shoulder but so
much more weight on poland a country
border in ukraine thank you very much
for uh sending troops the polish pm
grateful for uk troops but is it enough
do you send more troops prime minister
you for what you're doing these troops
already sent some of them arrived today
deployed for any humanitarian crisis
that could unfold
but here to work and the task daunting
the prime minister in difficulties at
home a tour of british troops is an easy
show of strength for any beleaguered
leader but the deployment is a sign too
that tensions are growing with
potentially catastrophic consequences
for our eastern allies you're announcing
the deployment of troops
350 here a thousand on standby
russia has amassed more than a hundred
thousand troops on the border
when you think about those numbers does
it frighten you a bit i think everybody
should be in no doubt that uh were
russia to be so foolish uh to make the
catastrophic mistake of invading any
part of ukraine the ukrainian army
which themselves number about 200 000
maybe 150 000 in reserve they will fight
and there will be uh bloodshed
and in his brief diplomatic mission at
the presidential palace in warsaw those
gathered here all aligned a prime
minister trying to tackle problems far
from home but he has plenty more to deal
with in his own backyard bethlehem sky
news warsaw